14 octobre 1944 le village d'herlies hng
près d'où lé mme
en allemagne une maison c'est la maison
du maréchal rommel
un nom qui évite évidemment bien des
explications
hélas ce 14 octobre il y a deux hommes
avec le maréchal omer ce sont deux
généraux le général burgdorf le général
miles et ses hommes sont apporte sont
venus apporter un rebelle un message
d'hitler il est accusé d'avoir trempé
dans le complot du 20 juillet contre le
führer
par conséquent il doit payer alors à lui
de choisir où le tribunal du peuple et
tout ce qui peut s'ensuivre c'est à dire
la pendaison ou le poison qu'il prendra
immédiatement et les deux généraux bon
d'orphée meisel ont apporté le poison
avec eux voilà donc le 14 octobre 1944
le dilemme tragique qui est proposé à
erwin rommel erwin hommel le plus
populaire de tous les généraux de
l'armée allemande non seulement le plus
populaire en allemagne mais aussi et
voilà la rareté le plus populaire auprès
de ses études voilà en effet ce que
présente de singulier le cas du maréchal
rommel
c'est par ses ennemis que ça les gens se
créer
en afrique du nord en libye les anglais
vivait dans la quiétude il avait chassé
les italiens et puis un beau jour un
général allemand est arrivé avec un
corps expéditionnaire et tout à coup les
anglais ont vu que ce général allemand
prenez là l'initiative est devenu une
sorte de tornades de mascaret de simone
et cette guerre qui en a découlé bien
les anglais ont remarqué qu'on la leur
faisait suivant les anciennes règles de
la guerre cette guerre les anglais ont
remarqué que c'était une guerre de
gentlemen et on a commencé à parler du
général rebelle et plus on a été plus on
a parlé du général rebelle et plus on
l'a admiré il y à un mot étonnant du
critique militaires britanniques lidl
art qui dit ceci les anglais ont voué à
romell une véritable affection et on ne
peut pas accuser liddell art de simples
de sympathies pro nazi alors voilà la
situation de romell situation étrange
oh je sais bien je sais bien qu'un livre
vient de paraître en allemagne un livre
qui paraît-il fait grand bruit
un livre qui se veut une entreprise de
démystification de romaine alors on le
dépeint sous des couleurs très sombres
et tout ce qu'on nous avait appris
admirer dans remet l'on veut l'anéantir
alors il faut attendre de lire ce livre
bien sûr mais on nous en a donné déjà
quelques résumés et nous savons qu'on le
dépeint dans ce livre comme
particulièrement brutale exigeant mais
ça nous le savions qu'ils étaient
brutales et qu'il était exigeant ce
n'est pas particulièrement à défaut
alors quand au reste quant à
l'entreprise elle-même va vous savez
tous les gens qui ont compté dans
l'histoire ont été victime de pareille
entreprise on veut
démythifier est très souvent c'est
plutôt l'auteur du livre lui même qui
s'amenuise vis-à-vis de ceux qui ne
lisent plus tôt que celui qu'il a voulu
amoindrir alors qu'ils aient eux mêmes
il est né près doom en 1891 son père est
un professeur de mathématiques cinq
enfants à la maison
le petit est bien le petit c'est à
l'enfant très timide à l'école peureux
réservés trop docile effacés et quand il
est au lycée bien il les mauvais élèves
le professeur dit le jour où rom elle
fera une dictée sans faute et bien nous
mourons un orchestre et nous partirons
passer une journée à la campagne alors
justement il vindicte et sans faute et
puis on ne part pas avec un orchestre
pour la campagne bien sûr alors il est
déçu il rentre dans sa médiocrité
tout change avec l'adolescence on a
l'impression d'une chrysalide qui éclate
d'un seul coup c'est un garçon énergie
qui se révèle car sont têtus qui sait
très bien où il va parce qu'ils se
passionnent pour ses études
se passionne aussi par l'aviation c'est
le lot de tous ces jeunes gens qui
vivent
vers les années 1910 et c'est justement
1910 qu'il choisit un métier sera
soldats il s'engage comme simple recrue
huit mois de classes en 1912 il est sous
lieutenant après être entré à l'école
milité pendant ses études à danser il a
rencontré une jeune fille elle s'appelle
lui si il en est tombé amoureux il
décide de se marier mais il faut
attendre attendre bien sûr que tout de
même le sous lieutenant
romel soit inséré dans l'existence et
ceux qui se présentent à lui
eh bien c'est la guerre au fond c'est
une chose normale pour un soldat il
apprend à faire la guerre et voilà qu'il
va faire la guerre et dès les premiers
engagements et bien remets les blessés
on le soigne il repart et il fera une
très belle guerre on le verra décoré de
la croix de fer d'avenir lieutenant et
en italie à la tête d'un bataillon il
fera quelque chose assez extraordinaire
sur le front italien et bien il fera dix
mille prisonniers en deux jours avec son
simple bataillon et puis un peu plus
tard le capitaine romel avec six hommes
s'emparent d'une garnison tout entière
alors il reçoit la décoration pour le
mérite qui est la plus élevée celle que
l'on réserve en général aux généraux et
puis voilà la fin de la guerre
normalement une revue devrait redevenir
civile il devrait entrer dans la vie
civile puisque le traité de versailles
n'a laissé à l'allemagne qu'une petite
armée de 100 mille hommes avec quatre
mille officiers
il a de la chance il est parmi les
quatre mille officiers parmi ceux qui
ont été retenus lors il sera instructeur
entre temps il s'est marié il s'est
marié d'ailleurs pendant la guerre en
1916 il vit maintenant avec sa femme il
est très heureux semble-t-il nul me
semble que ce fût aménage unis que le
ménage romel ils auront un petit garçon
en 1928
on l'appellera manfred et puis il est
nommé major commandant d'un corps de
chasseurs alpins à gosselaar en basse
saxe il arrive dans ce corps il a tout
même déjà 43 ou 44 ans et il ya des tout
jeunes officiers
on est en montagne et les officiers
comme c'est l'hiver propose aux majeurs
avec peut-être une petite arrière pensée
de faire une balade à skis de monter
là-haut tout là-haut épique de
redescendre mais il n'y a pas de
remonter siège à cette époque-là pas le
remonte pente plus tôt et on fait ça
piermont et fatigant puis après on
descend et le major grommelle les frais
comme l'ail il est là oh et puis il
redescend plus vite que tous les autres
il le premier en bas alors tout de même
on salue en était un peu fatigué par
cette épreuve et le major hamel 10
messieurs c'était tellement intéressant
tellement amusant que nous allons
recommencer si vous voulez bien et voilà
que prix l'entraînent ces jeunes
officiers là où une seconde fois et on
redescend encore plus vite ils sont
absolument épuisé mais lui d'admirables
de désinvolture il dit monsieur vraiment
cette promenade m'a enchanté voulez vous
que nous recommencions une troisième
fois et recommence
de sorte que les officiers les jeunes
officiers sont complètement prêt du coma
lorsqu'il arrivera en bas et à ce moment
là alors qu'ils pensent enfin les boire
un verre et fumer une cigarette et se
reposer le major rebelle divers
maintenant je vois là bas une piste de
slalom je vous engage à y aller avec ma
nous allons passer une excellente heures
maintenance lors la partie en ce moment
là les jeunes officiers on pensait qu'il
fallait pas mettre leur majeure en
difficulté et voyez vous c'est une image
de rebelle sa recette une image
on la retrouvera plus tard souvent c'est
un homme qui s'impose d'emblée à ceux
qui doivent lui obéir et qui ai je parlé
d'exigence tout à l'heure c'est vrai
qu'il est exigeant avec ses hommes avec
ses officiers mais il est surtout très
exigeant avec lui même et c'est pour ça
que les hommes léman 1935 quelqu'un qui
arrive à gosses là c'est tout simplement
hitler à il fallait qu'il arrive dans
qu'il entre dans cette histoire il clair
connaît rebelles parce que rebelle a
publié quelques années avant un livre
pendant qu'il était un strict
un livre qui s'intitule l'infanterie
attaquer c'est un excellent manuel de
stratégie et ce manuel a lu un lecteur
adolf hitler
et puis adolf hitler est arrivé au
pouvoir en 33 rebelles vermelles fait
pas de politique mais il a regardé
autour de lui les nazis et il n'a pas
beaucoup paix mais il dit quel dommage
que cette bande de voyous constitue
l'entourage d'hitler oui parce qu'il
fait une différence
il n'aime pas les nazis mais il éprouve
pour hitler du respect pour lui vite
l'air est un idéaliste et c'est un homme
qui unifiera à l'allemagne c'est un
homme qui préservera l'allemagne des
communistes
alors respect pour hitler et quand
hitler se présente en 1935 ago cela est
bien le major rebelle est prêt à le
recevoir
lorsqu'il reçoit un officier ss qui lui
annonce qu il défilera devant hitler
mais que devant lui défileront les ss il
n'en est pas question dit le major
remets pas de ss devant l'armée
l'officier ss 120 interloqué revient
instants après il me l'air et goebbels
convoque romel auprès d'eux il arrive
prêt à subir une algarade et trouve deux
hommes souriants qui disent majors c'est
une erreur naturellement les ss à
doivent pas passer devant l'armée alors
vous défileraient le premier devant le
führer et c'est ce qu'il fait à la tête
de ces hommes est ensuite hitler lui
serre la main et le félicite c'est la
première fois que les deux hommes se
parlent
ensuite il redevient instructeurs et les
colonels et hitler se souvient de lui
lorsqu'il entre en tchécoslovaquie à
l'automne de 38 et c'est lui qui sera le
héros mail chef de l'escort d'hitler et
de nouveau il sera chef de l'escort
d'hitler en mars 39 contre hitler
entrera à prague et le colonel rebelle
se voit poser une question par hitler
qui lui dit bon je suis dans la ville
maintenant qu'est ce que vous me
conseillez colonel est bien dit romel
mein führer je vous conseille d'aller
tout droit aura chin c'est le château
qui est tout à fait au centre de bram
d'aller tout droit aura chin en voiture
découverte et sans escorte
party poker mais hitler suit le conseil
il gagne alors maintenant remet elle est
un homme auquel il pensait en août 40
ans nous 39
romel et major général et attachés à
l'état major du ferrat de sorte que rom
elle sera aux côtés d'hitler pendant
toute la campagne de pologne
et là il découvrira la force
considérable des blindés il apprendra
que dans la guerre moderne larmes
essentiel c'est les blacks
de sorte que maintenant son rêve c'est
de commander une formation blindés et
c'est exactement ce qu'il obtient dès le
10 mai 40 il va foncer à la tête de sa
division blindée de sa pente s'est re
division
d'abord en belgique il franchit la meuse
et puis ensuite il fonce sur l'île il
participe à la grande manoeuvre
d'encerclement des franco britannique il
foncera sur la somme sur la scène
s'engagera en picardie en normandie
livrera bataille et gagnera à saint
valery en caux et ensuite s'emparera de
la ville de cherbourg campagne éclair
campagne remarquable il fait pendant ces
quelques jours car finalement hélas ça
n'est que quelques jours il fait février
41 rome elle est chez lui à harlingen en
permission
lorsqu'il reçoit un coup de téléphone il
est convoqué auprès du maréchal von
bronchite ch et également auprès du
chancelier
il va voir bronchite ch d'abord qui lui
apprend qu'il est nommé commandant d'un
corps expéditionnaire en afrique du nord
en libye il est commandé il commandera
une division blindée et une division
légère il doit partir sur le champ mais
auparavant voir hitler et voix et l'est
éclair lui dit qu'on l'a désigné à lui
comme l'homme le plus compétent pour
rétablir la situation en afrique du nord
quelle est elle cette situation
et bien dès septembre 40 les italiens
commandé par le maréchal graziani ont
attaqué à la frontière de l'egypte les
anglais commandée par le général wave et
ils ont enfoncé littéralement les
anglais car les italiens avaient une
supériorité numérique considérable et un
matériel beaucoup plus importante les
angles et les italiens sont allés
prendre position à sidi barrani et de la
car vraiment les forces anglaises
étaient presque misérable de là ils
auraient pu foncer jusqu'à alexandre
sans rencontrer beaucoup d'opposition
c'est ce que grazziani n'a pas fait il a
préféré se fortifier dans sidi barrani
attendre un peu plus tard il a eu tort
d'attendre parce qu'entre temps ce sont
les anglais qui se sont fortifiés et
wave l oma 140 a attaqué dans l'autre
sens a bousculé grazziani la chasse et
de sidi barrani appris sur le long de la
côte bardia et puis ensuite tobrouk et
enfin bengazi la cyrénaïque était perdu
pour graziani les italiens venait de
rencontrer une défaite est craint et
c'est là qu'ils claire a décidé
d'intervenir car il jugeait le point
infiniment stratégique qu'il avait
raison et il a décidé d'envoyer romain
et en mars avril 1941 voici donc rebel
rebel en afrique du nord
et voici romel qui aussitôt le trouvant
même plus à côté de lui
graziani qui s'est démis de ses
fonctions rebelles qui prend le
commandement de son corps
expéditionnaire qu'on appellera bientôt
l'afrika corps je dis bien l'afrique
accord car on m'a signalé qu'il s'était
la vraie prononciation quoique tout le
monde et moi le premier et 10 jusqu'ici
afrika korps avril mars avril 41 rome
elle bouscule les anglais reprend
bengazi traverse le désert et vient
buter de vente groupe
il met le siège de vente au groupe et il
n'arrive pas à prendre le brocart troqué
très fortifiée et pendant l'été de 41
c'est la guerre de positions chacun
s'observe révèle est remplacé par
rothschild et set au tchèque qui va
donner l'offensive et qui va chasser
romel de ses positions voilà que remet
elle repère tout le terrain conquis et
voilà maintenant qu'il a reperdu lui
aussi la cyrénaïque
ce n'est qu'en janvier en janvier 42 que
rebelle va attaquer de nouveau il fonce
et cette fois c'est la grande campagne
c'est celle qui assurera la gloire
éternelle de romell parce qu'il prend
benghazi
cette fois il prend tobrouk cette fois
il prend barguil prend tout y est
les anglais reflux reflux reflux sans
cesse le voilà à la frontière de
l'egypte il franchi cette frontière il
est temps l'egypte qu'il prend sidi
barrani il est là il a gagné et le monde
entier parle de rome c'est alors que
hitler le fait maréchal
il est maintenant le maréchal rommel et
il est maintenant sûr devant des
positions qui s'appelle elle à la mène
il ne se doute pas que sur ses positions
d'elle à la mène la temps incertain
montgomery il est malade
romel à cette époque-là très malin vous
savez les conditions de vie étaient très
dures il ya des mois qu'il est là dans
le désert dans la chaleur qu'il se bat
les hommes d'ailleurs sont très souvent
atteints de dysenterie il y aura
peut-être plus de morts par la
dysenterie que par balles dans cette
campagne il est lui même très malades
tient à peine debout on le traîne dans
un camion il a le x extrêmement malade
est également sa tension qui a galopé
qui est devenu très très trop grande
trop forte et les médecins le chip lead
aller se soigner en europe il part et
c'est l'art qui sur son passage qu'il
rencontrera d'abord mussolini le dolce
en italie et puis un peu plus tard qu'il
rencontrera en allemagne est clair qu'il
le félicitera mais à qui il demandera il
ne cessera de demander des renforts
disant ça n'est pas possible on me
laisse réduit à moi même je n'ai pas
assez d'hommes je n'ai pas ces deux
chars il me faut encore des chats et les
sens c'est ce que l'essence arrive non
elle n'arrive pas il faut dire que tous
les convois aube qui arrive qui porte
tout ce matériel et ses rangs sort en
afrique du nord convoi allemand convoi
italien sont très souvent couler par la
flotte britannique de l'année
tehran et alors ils se soignent le 24
octobre un coup de téléphone c'est
hitler qu'il appelle lui-même et qui lui
dit montgomery a pris l'offensive elle à
la mène alors remet l'europe c'est la
grande bataille d'el alamein là où
montgomery et ses alliés jeudi et les
alliés parce qu'il n'ya pas que les
britanniques qu'il y a aussi les
australiens il ya les néo zélandais il y
aura aussi dans cette guerre quelques
français montgomery a pris l'initiative
et montgomery va battre romel et cette
fois c'est la gloire de montgomery qu'on
chantera voici que rom elles refluent
reflux reflux sans cesse vers l'ouest il
perd tout et même tripoli il perdra
tripoli ça n'était plus possible
les anglais avaient reçu sans cesse du
matériel des renforts de toutes sortes
les nouveaux chat anglais était très
supérieure aux chars allemands
il était bien ravitaillés par e mail
alors il de nouveau lui ravoir hitler il
le suppléera elle durable nous avons
perdu la partie en afrique du nord
il faut maintenant sauver les hommes
laissons le matériel tant pis mais
sauvons les hommes
embarquant les hommes et hitler refusé à
ce moment là
romel qui jusque là avait toujours une
cette sorte de confiance dans heatley
remet les déçus par hitler c'est sa
première grande déception d'hitler une
voix cet homme s'accrocher à
l'impossible ne pas faire réellement la
réflexion qui convient devant la réalité
sédiments fins ou va-t-il cet homme là
qu'est ce qu'il veut le sait-il lui-même
il retournera en afrique du nord
il sera en tunisie livrera une bataille
aux américains parce qu'entre temps les
américains ont débarqué et les voici
face à face aux mets les américains ils
barrent les américains c'est sa dernière
victoire de nouveau très mal à la gorge
entouré de pansements ne tenant plus
debout
il repart pour l'europe et bientôt
l'afrika corps
existe rappelé
il est allé voir heatley encore et
hitler l'a reçue dans son repaire du
loup là-bas en prusse orientale il a
trouvé un hitler très différents un
éclair qui ne plastronne plus un hitler
qui est la seule avec lui
hermel aux lui dire mais mein führer est
ce que vous croyez encore que nous
pourrons remporter la victoire sur l'un
ou l'autre front et d'air c'est l'un des
rares moments qu'on lui connaisse où il
est à vous est la ligne la vérité
profonde et les répondants je le crois
plus alors dire aux mails il faut tirer
la leçon de ça il faut faire quelque
chose
oui d'hitler je sais je sais que je
devrai traiter avec l'un ou l'autre et
c'est eux qui ne veulent pas traiter
avec moi et leurs larmes elle sent que
vraiment cet homme pense plus à lui même
qu'à l'allemagne puisque ils nous font
puisqu'il sait qu'il ne gagnera plus la
guerre ils devraient au moins se retirer
puisqu'on ne veut pas traiter avec lui
et que d'autres traitent ainsi épargne
réty l'allemagne la catastrophe finale
voilà ce que pense rebelles et il part
il part littéralement angoissé et on va
le soigner pendant sept semaines dans un
hôpital dans cet hôpital et recevra les
camarades des amis et ceux ci lui
ouvriront les yeux lui diront des choses
qu'ils épouvante lui la mener sa guerre
en afrique et il croyait que tout le
monde l'a mené de la même manière et non
pas du tout et voilà qu'on lui apprend
les atrocités en pologne les atrocités
en russie voilà qu'on lui apprend
l'existence des camps de concentration
voilà qu'on lui apprend l'extermination
des juifs
tous ils découvrent tout dans quelques
jours en quelques semaines et il est
encore plus éprouvante et il te dis mais
enfin voilà où on et l'allemagne et à
part qui par la faute de qui il ira
encore voir une fois est clair
et lui parlera jeudi ramène à une
floraison
voilà ce que j'ai appris ce que vous
pensez vous continuer dans cette voie
vous ne pouvez pas tolérer l'intolérable
et hitler et furieux il lui répond par
des mots blessants et même il y aura une
algarade dans une de ces rencontres avec
terry clair le chassant littéralement en
mêle tournant les talons et dans
l'antichambre il sentira une map se pose
sur son épaule c'est hitler qui est
sorti et qui le rattrape et lui
d'excusés moi je suis un peu nerveux en
ce moment
alors tout cela pour remet les quelque
chose c'est comme un monde qui
s'effondre et il comprend que les crimes
nazis
finalement ce sont aussi les crimes de
heatley il a accordé par une sorte de
faiblesse jusque là les circonstances
atténuantes est clair que maintenant non
ils les accords de plus tout ça c'est à
mettre dans le même sac
c'est le temps où il est nommé en italie
commandant d'un groupe d'armées ça ne
dure pas très longtemps parce que à
l'automne de 1943 il est nommé
inspecteur des défenses côtières depuis
le danemark jusqu'à la frontière
espagnole
c'est beaucoup
le voilà au danemark avec l'un de ses
adjoints l'amiral rouge
il inspecte en quelques jours les
défenses côtières de toute façon le
débarquement car on attend que ça le
débarquement le débarquement ça n'est
pas là au danemark qui n'interviendra de
sorte qu'il part rapidement pour la
france il s'installe à la roche guyon et
comme inspecteur et bien il respecte
mais vous savez rebelles inspectant ça
n'est pas la moindre des choses car ce
qu'il a inspectés c'est ce qu'on appelle
le mur de l'atlantique alors le voilà
qui circulent tout le long de
l'atlantique et de la manche
ils partent dès le matin 6 heures du
matin roulent toute la journée va de
cantonnement cantonnement de qg en qg
rencontre des chefs de groupe des chefs
de corps d'armée des jeunes des généraux
des colonels des commandants des simples
soldats hiller pas une les interroge ils
se rend compte par lui même et il
s'aperçoit que le mur de l'atlantique
c'est une gigantesque plaisanterie et
oui c'est vrai il y à nice sa demie
râble ouvrage bétonné on les
photographies sans cesse et ce sont eux
qui paraissent dans la presse mais c'est
ouvrage bétonné combien y en at il
il y en a de loin en loin alors c'est
vrai que sur certaines plages lie à de
l'artillerie mais cette intrigue n'est
même pas couvertes on n'a même pas le
temps ni l'occasion ni la volonté de
créer des abris bétonner pour cette
artillerie l état là sous un ciel ouvert
risquant d'être anéanties par les
bombardements quand on voudra quand les
autres nous devrons alors qu'il prend
des initiatives
ils demandent que l'on fasse ceci que
l'on fasse cela il est 10e à lui tout
seul mais voilà ce qui n'a pas
l'autorité il doit tout transmettre au
général au maréchal von rundstedt qui
prend les décisions
alors il ne se sent pas à l'aise car
enfin lui ce qu'il aime c'est comme ma
vie là bas comment l'afrique c'est
comment des écoles obéissent directement
il demande un commandement indépendant
il l'obtient et il est au début de 44
commandant des forces de la hollande à
la loi
lorelei le travail et son historien
britannique desmond y en qui l'admirent
nous dit qu'il est heureux qu'il n'ait
pas été nommé plutôt qu'il est heureux
qu'il n'est au fond que quelques mois
parce que ce qu'il a accompli justement
dans ces quelques mois est étonnant il a
renforcé considérablement ses défenses
qui n'existait qu'à l'état d'hypothèse
c'est ainsi que les mines et bien en
trois ans on avait posé deux millions de
mines on était content d'avoir posé deux
millions et demi
savez-vous ce qu'en quatre mois sera
romel il posera 4 millions le mime et
son projet s'étant posé 50 millions demi
et peut-être 100 millions s'il le peut
et imaginer qu'il ait réussi alors les
alliés débarquent en caisse qu'ils
auraient trouvé un véritable tapis de
mines s'étendant jusqu'aux loin à
l'intérieur du territoire français le
débarquement échoué et pour ses mines
car on lui en livres par assez bien il
d'utiliser des vieux onu il fait
fabriquer les mines avec des vieux aux
obus et puis la vente des gadgets sur
les plages pour empêcher le débarquement
des chars et des hommes ils implantent
des pics et partout sur les plages ce
n'est pas grand chose mais au bout de
ses piques et ils installent des mines
les mine sont cachés par la marée elles
sont attachés avec des cordes âgées
elles devront sauter au moindre choc
alors voilà tout ce que fait rebelles et
en même temps il est lucide
en même temps il sait le risque immense
que pour l'allemagne
car il sait que si les alliés débarquent
à peine auront ils mis le pied sur la
terre on ne pourra plus les chasser il
le sait parce qu'il sait à quel point
l'aviation alliée et toute puissante il
l'a vu en afrique et il a souffert de
l'absence de la luftwaffe
alors ce qu'il essaye de démontrer
aujourd'hui au commandement à ceux qui
entourent hitler c'est qu'il faudra
cloud et les alliés dans la mer le jour
du débarquement
ce n'est pas la thèse du haut
commandement le haut commandement tu dis
qu'il faut les laisser poser le pied sur
la terre et ensuite on les ondes et
rejettera la mère rom elle n'est pas ta
vie et c'est lui qui arrive alors ils
préparent de son mieux ce qu'il faut
pour faire face au débarquement sans
croire qu'il puisse gagner 7 un climat
difficile pour un soldat et il est là
dans ce paradoxe c'est qu'il ne croit
plus à la victoire
ils ne croient plus à la victoire
il le sait il le dit autour de lui et en
même temps ils préparent tout pour
éviter la nef et maintenant il va plus
loin il sait que cette catastrophe dont
il sent que l'allemagne est menacée
il sent qu'on va anéantir l'alma si on
n'arrête pas la guerre eh bien on pourra
maintenant éviter cette catastrophe
qu'en se débarrassant et voilà au début
de 1944 la réflexion à laquelle est
arrivée erwin rommel et il ne fait pas
qu'y penser
il agit
depuis quelques mois des gens en
allemagne étaient arrivés à la même
conclusion il fallait sauver l'allemagne
pour sauver l'allemagne se débarrasser
niclet ces gens là étaient des conjurés
qui s'étaient réunis à la tête de la
conspiration
le bourgmestre de leipzig le docteur
coeur de l'air est aussi le général bec
ancien chef d'état major général limogé
par éclairs à la veille de la guerre et
ces gens avaient réuni dans toute
l'allemagne tout un réseau de
conspirateurs il y avait là des jambes
de l'état-major des gens du haut
commandement des hauts fonctionnaires et
ces gens se réunissent et
clandestinement pour prévoir le moment
où il serait temps et comment aussi on
se débarrasserait d'hitler et parmi les
conduirait il y avait un certain docteur
strul in bourgmestre de stuttgart extra
line était un ami de robert au mail on
avait cité son nom dès les premiers
temps de la conspiration
parce que ce n'était pas tout de libérer
l'allemagne d'hitler qu'est-ce qu'on
mettrait après hitler
alors on n'avait cherché un un homme
accepté par tous un homme populaire
un homme accepte et aussi par les autres
par les alliés un homme estimé par les
alliés n'y en avait pas tellement parmi
eux au personnel allemand et un v1
romaine et c'est alors que les conjurés
ont décidé mais voilà l'homme qui
succédera à hitler ce sera romaine
oh moi
d'où 1943 le docteur str line avait avec
coeur de leurs rédigé un document
ce document c'était une demande pour que
soit arrêté
les persécutions des juifs et des
églises pour que soit rétabli les droits
civiques pour que le parti n'exerce plus
sa mainmise sur la justice
ce document il ressemble bien astres
lynch trop line ancien nazi il faut le
dire mais qui en 1938 lors de la sphère
de la tchécoslovaquie s'étaient séparés
brutalement dit
et depuis il était anti nazi et une
militer contre hitler depuis 1939
en tant que bourgmestre de stuttgart qui
l'a sauvé de nombreux juifs pendant la
guerre est également et ça nous devons
nous français nous en souvenir également
25 résistants français condamné à mort
qui l'a sauvé halo reach trolling
demandé officiellement tout cela que la
politique de l'allemagne nazie change en
quelque sorte il avait envoyé ce
document au ministre de l'intérieur on
lui avait répondu si vous continuez dans
cette voie vous serez pendu alors il
avait compris ce n'est pas par les voies
légales
on pourrait s'en tirer et le document il
avait remis un jour à madame romel et
madame rom elle l'a remis à romell en
décembre 1943 il promet là était
passionnément intéressés par ce document
parce que c'était ses idées qu'il y
avait dans ses documents leur remet elle
a souhaité rencontrer ce trait et la
réunion a eu lieu à erding
en février 1944 février 1944 imaginé ces
deux hommes qui sont la face à face ces
deux hommes qui vont parler ensemble
entre 5 et 6 heures oui six heures de
rang et tout y passe et le passé
éclaire l'avenir l allemagne est ce
qu'il fallait faire à tout prix pour
sauver l'allemagne et stirling parle de
la conspiration elle dit armel il faut
que vous donniez votre nom au mouvement
nous avons besoin de vous rebelles n'est
pas contre il lit il faut encore essayer
il faut encore essayer de convaincre
hitler et si nous n'y parvenons pas eh
bien oui je serai avec vous
un peu plus tard on nomme comme chef
d'état-major de romell le général said
el c'est une chance car le général
chahine d'aller lui même un des conjurés
et c'est lui qui établira désormais le
contact entre les conjurés et rohmer est
aussi le contact entre un autre conjuré
de haut rang qui est en france qui est
le général von stülpnagel cube nagl
gouverneur militaire de la france c'est
le 15 mai 1944 cas mareil marly brède
saint germain se rencontrent ce tout
nagl et romel et ils sont d'accord on va
prévoir des négociations de paix avec
l'ouest avec alsa noël avec montgomery
mais pour cela il faut se débarrasser
d'hitler et voici ce qu'on attendait ce
qu'on attendait c'est-à-dire le 6 juin
le débarquement des plages envahi
l'armada alliés et ce jour là le 6 juin
romel est à herlings
il revient sur le champ il s'est produit
ce qu'il redoutait avant toute chose
c'est à dire que les alliés ont pris
pied et avant le soir du 6 juin ils ont
deux têtes de pont et comme l'a prévu
romel l'aviation dans le ciel
l'aviation qui est là omniprésente qui
couvre le ciel qui obscurcit presse que
le soleil et les colonnes blindées
allemandes arrêté cloués au sol
ne pouvant pas faire leur mouvement tout
est arrêté par l'aviation
il faut penser à cet homme ma soeur rom
elle qui est là entre deux solutions
et surtout entre deux actions
l'action de se battre pour empêcher les
alliés d'aller plus loin de s'implanter
en europe et en même temps l'espoir de
mettre fin à la guerre ça n'est
peut-être pas aussi contradictoires
qu'on pourrait le penser parce que oui
il veut négocier mais il veut négocier
en position de force si possible alors
il arrête les armes et comme il le peut
et 200 mieux il se bat bien le 12 juin
romel adresse un message est clair il
tient sa promesse
on essaiera at il dit d'influencé
éclairé il dit où ils disent allez plus
possible la bataille est perdue
nous trouvons plus pire il y a déjà eu
cent mille morts et blessés cent mille
hommes hors de combat de nous de notre
côté nous n'avons reçu que 4000 et 5000
nos forces s'amenuisent ne pouvons pas
tenir
alors il faut tirer les conséquences de
la situation et daimler lettre morte
rien rien du tout le 17 juin
hitler vient important conférence à 60 à
la conférence il y as rebelles et von
rundstedt iphone anstett rebelles par et
10 à me plaire
nous ne pouvons pas continuer le combat
dans ces conditions il faut mettre fin à
ce combat au tout au moins ils sont
retraités il faut commencer une retraite
jamais l'air par le retraite
ainsi il est toujours le même un psy ne
comprend pas il ne veut pas comprendre
il s'obstine ils jettent l'allemagne à
terre rebelles communiquent hp dell ses
avis et saïd el les communique aux
conjurés et maintenant on a décidé on
tuera hitler le 20 juillet
il n'est pas sûr que rome elle est
certes déçu il n'est pas sûr que vos
mails et su qu'on allait tuer hitler
mais comment n'aurait-il pas penser que
le mouvement qu'il approuvait pouvait
aboutir à autre chose
le 20 juillet 44 en prusse orientale à
son quartier général le colonel von
stauffenberg sera chargé de déposer une
bombe rebelles ne verra rien de
l'attentât du 20 juillet parce que le 17
juillet il est dans sa voiture il quitte
tac 16 heures le quartier général de
cèpes dietrich
car on lui a téléphoné que les alliés
viennent de réussir une nouvelle percée
alors il part pour son propre quartier
général il se dirige vers libara livarot
et l'âme il aperçoit au dessus de
livarot vie bombardier alors il leur
donne que sa voiture s'engage sur la
route de vimoutiers
il roule sur cette route de vimoutiers
lorsque deux chasseurs bombardiers
arrive volant en rase mottes et venant
aux vendeurs un ordre aux chauffeurs
daniel vite vite
ou les tourner à droite à 300 mètres il
ya un petit chemin avec des arbres et le
chauffeur précipite la voiture vers ce
petit chemin avec ce père césar mais les
chasseurs censure beaucoup plus vite et
tout à coup c'est la mitraille and c'est
le chauffeur qui est atteint blessé
grièvement qui perd le contrôle de son
véhicule la voiture qui glisse qui
tourne qui tourne sur elle même quitté
crasse dans un fossé au mail a été
blessé grièvement un oeil et puis sa
tête a porté contre la voiture
trois fois il est là inconscient il
était
jeté hors de la voiture il gît sur le
sol on le traîne à l'abri on le portera
chez toujours inconscient chez des
religieuses françaises c'est un médecin
français qui lui donnera ses soins il
dira il est perdu on en portera on le
portera dans un hôpital militaire a
berné on le soigne les médecins
diagnostiquent trois fractures du crâne
2 à la tempe et une à la basse en même
temps blessure à l'oeil et nombreuses
coupures et contusions au visage perdu
c'est bien on l'a cru et il reprend
conscience et quelques jours après bien
sûr prend tout le monde par sa vitalité
le conduit à l'hôpital militaire du
vésinet près de paris c'est là qu'on le
soignera et des amis venus le voir
quelques jours après le trouveront à
leur immense surprise assis sur le lit
alors qu'on l'obligé à nouveau resté
étendu il a repris toute sa vitalité il
va très bien et même quelques jours
après on a mis le trouve en train de se
raser le 8 août il exige qu'on le
transporte en allemagne chez lui à
harlingen il en a assez de l'hôpital et
on le transporteur ligne il est soigné
par des médecins de heaulme où il se
rend régulièrement on vient également
les soigner chez lui et enfin il est là
avec sa femme son fils lui manfred est
mobilisé quoique n'ayant que quinze ans
vous savez on mobilise tout le monde à
cette époque là et madame mais les
surprises parce qu' elle ne reçoit pas
de demande de nouvelle personne
n'appelle du quartier général d'hitler
personnes aucune personnalité nazis
n'appelle kite elle n'appelle payolle
n'appelle pas les le haut-commandement
n'appelle pas personne c'est le silence
alors qu'autrefois rebelles étaient
tellement choyée mais pourquoi et bien
c'est qu'entre temps l'attentât du 20
juillet a eu lieu et oui je te refais
une berge comme il en avait reçu l'ordre
a posé une bombe dans une serviette
aux pieds d'hitler sous la table la ld
partie et puis voilà incroyable le
hasard la coïncidence inouïe
quelqu'un a été gêné par cette serviette
qui étaient là sous la table a pris la
serviette et la porte est ailleurs
derrière un pilier et quand la bombe a
explosé elle n'a pas tué mais il n'est
plus resté de la salle qu un
enchevêtrement que hitler montrera un
peu plus tard à mussolini venu lui
rendre visite mais surtout la répression
a commencé une répression implacable
impitoyable on arrête les gens par
centaines par milliers
tous ceux qui ont touché à la tente à
tous ceux qui n'y ont pas touché tous
ceux qui sont soupçonnés
il y aura des gens qui seront traduits
devant le tribunal du peuple nomé
spécialement un tribunal d'une cruauté
inimaginable
les gens paraissent devant ce tribunal
ont leur enlever leurs bretelles de
manière à ce qu'ils soient obligés de
tenir leurs pantalons tout ça est
lamentable docteur coeur dallaire par et
devancé tribunal et n'y aura que les
sentences de mort de mort de mort
ces gens là ont été torturées longuement
avant l'audience on les tue long les
paons et on les paons avec des cordes à
piano pour que leur agonie dure plus
longtemps alors on a arrêté beaucoup de
monde et stumpf nagl qui quand il a
appris par téléphone l'attentât a cru qu
hitler était mort a déclenché le
dispositif à paris il a fait arrêter les
ss et les membres de la gestapo et après
il a appris qu hitler n'était pas mort
et quand on l'a convoqué à berlin il a
su pourquoi alors sur nagl vieux
combattant de la guerre 14-18 arrêté sa
voiture près de verdun est descendu et
s'est tiré une balle dans la tête
hélas si c'est raté quand on l'a il
s'est éveillée à l'hôpital il s'est
juste aveuglé et quand il s'est sorti de
son inconscience à l'hôpital il a dit
romel il à répéter
romel romel et voilà des propos qui ne
sont pas comme on dit
tombé dans l'oreille d'un sourd tous les
gens qui étaient là à son chevet en ôter
aux là l'homme qui dans son inconscience
parler de rebel efi lâche pas et d'un
spa enel on a arrêté
alors quand on arrêtait spyder remet
elle a compris qu'une sorte de nas
refermer autour de lui et puis il ya
aussi les papiers de galère on les a
trouvés chez lui et là il y avait la
liste du prochain gouvernement
président du reich le maréchal erwin
rommel et ça on l'a trouvée là noir sur
blanc savait les allemands beaucoup
d'ordres mais quelques pas trop au nord
ça fait beaucoup de mal la santé der
wien rebelles n'étaient pas mauvaises il
allait de mieux en mieux mais il
comprenait pas ce silence
le silence a été rompu le 7 octobre coup
de téléphone de kite et erika i tell lui
même qui appelait au mail et qui lui
disait on vous attend berlin un train
spécial vous partira le 9 et vous
conduira le dise à berlin pourquoi faire
dire aux mails et bien on va discuter de
votre prochaine emploi alors qu'il
annonce à ses médecins qu'il parlait
médecins se récrie il n'est pas question
qu'ils prennent à 37 pas possible ils le
doivent
il ne peut pas n'est pas en état de
partir d'assister à des conférences à
berlin c'est la folie en mail téléphone
qui ne peut pas mener et le 13 octobre
on annonce l'arrivée de deux généraux
les généraux burgdorf et meisel
le lendemain six heures du matin manfred
arrive en permission
il trouve son père déjà debout mais leur
soucieux qu'ils prennent ensemble leur
petit déjeuner puis monfreid domaine son
père faire une promenade on revient et à
midi juste une voiture à paris les deux
généraux sont là plus sain l'adjoint un
certain airen dernière présentation à la
moyenne mangou fred rebelles l'officier
de rebelles en salle ding
puis les deux généraux demandent être
seul avec romain il reste seul avec lui
pendant une aube ou d'une heure madame
rebelles qui dans sa chambre voit surgir
son mari et elle lui voit sur le visage
quelque chose dira t'elle de terribles
élire mais qu'est ce que tu as qu'est-ce
que vous avez 15 se voit qu est-ce que
vous avez vous êtes malade il répond je
suis venu vous dire adieu
dans un quart d'heure je serais mort il
se récrie comment pourquoi ils
expliquent ils sont venus me dire que je
suis soupçonné d'avoir eu partie liée
avec les conjurés du 20 juillet alors le
marché est simple où le tribunal du
peuple ou le poison ils ont le poison
avec il faut que tu il faut que vous
choisissiez le tribunal du peuple du mal
à m'en mêle non dire au maire non je ne
veux pas être pendus par hitler
et puis ici je choisis le poison il me
jure qu'il ne vous toucheront pas niveau
du mon fils que vous aurez une pension
et que même j'aurai droit à des obsèques
nationales
voici mon frère qui rentrent tout joyeux
dans la pièce et il se fige en voyant
l'air de son père et les larmes de ça
mais lui aussi a droit aux adieux
il est désespéré à lignières a droit aux
adieux et puis rebelles par il a posé sa
casquette sur sa tête et brandit son
bâton de maréchal et il monte dans la
voiture la voiture disparaît 25 minutes
plus tard le téléphone sonne c'est al
din guerre qui décoche ehrenberg heure
est à la pareille à capitaine dit
ehrenberg hernie tragique nouvelle une
chose épouvantable
le maréchal rommel a été saisie en
voiture d'une hémorragie cérébrale
il est mort j'arrive et il arrivera en
effet pour présenter ses condoléances à
madame romel qui ne voudra pas le
recevoir
al din guérira un peu plus tard à
l'hôpital du loup on apportait le corps
et voudra rester seul avec son chef et
son ami on le lui interdire à l'après
midi ce sera madame romel et manfred qui
viendront à l'hôpital ils parleront
médecin chef qui leur dira comme amener
le corps à 13h25 on m'a redonné de faire
une piqûre pour stimuler le coeur je les
fais pas de résultats mais on m'a
signalé qu'il n'y aurait pas de top 6 et
madame ormel s'est approché du corps
elle a lu alors sur ce le visage de son
mari une immense expression de mépris et
quand on regarde aujourd'hui encore le
masque mortuaire de rebelles on y
retrouve ce mépris
c'est encore le mépris que l'ira la
soeur de rom elle a couru quelques
heures plus tard et qui ne connaît pas
les circonstances de la mort de son
frère liam et oui il y adeux mépris sur
son visage alors oui on avait promis des
obsèques nationales et elles vont avoir
lieu ses obsèques nationales elles vont
avoir lieu le 18 octobre
et là dans la ville d'oulu on a mobilisé
tout ce qu'on l'a pu trouver de troupes
de troupes qui venaient de toute la
région
et voici le maréchal von rundstedt lui
même qu'ils fassent amende frais drôme
elle va prononcer l'oraison funèbre
et oui c'est lui qui est chargé de cette
tâche et il parle il signale il signale
que rebelle non seulement a servi son
pays mais a servi le führer il termine
en disant son corps son coeur
appartenait aux furies fondtech qui
dépose maintenant une magnifique gerbe
au nom du glay alors on portera le
cercueil sur une prolonge d'artillerie
toute la ville pleure le héros le corps
traverse la ville et on va le conduire
au d'abord au four crématoire
et oui c'est la décision qui a été pris
en effet il faut brûler ce corps il ne
faut pas que jamais un jour on aille
analyser les entrailles de ce corps
alors on le brûle et les cendres on les
réunit dans une boîte et cette boîte on
va l'inhumer dans le petit cimetière der
linden
un petit cimetière de campagne qui en
terrasses s'étend jusqu'à une rivière
qui coule dans une paiement cela tout au
bas et là dans un angle du cimetière on
inaugure à tous ceux qui restent der
wien rebelles plus tard madame remet
elle dira que pendant la cérémonie oui
parce qu'elle a assisté à toute cette
cérémonie
eh oui pendant qu'on saluer le corps de
rebelles pendant qu'on lui rendait les
homards pendant qu'on lui présentait les
arbres pendant que von rundstedt faisait
son éloge funèbre
pendant qu'il jurait que le coeur de
rome elle appartenait au führer et bien
madame remet elle a écouté entendu tout
cela et elle dira plus tard qu'elle a
failli se dresser dix fois qu'elle a
failli relais
c'est faux c'est un mensonge vous mentez
tout ça n'est pas vrai elle ne l'a pas
fait elles savaient ce qui était arrivé
aux familles de tous les conjurés du 20
juillet 44 elle savait que l'on avait
arrêté jusqu'à des cousins éloignés
elle savait que si elle faisait cela on
tuerait manfred alors elle ne l'a pas
fait mais quelque temps plus tard elle a
reçu une lettre officielle crawl
enveloppe en tête
cacher on lui annonçait que la décision
avait été prise en haut lieu d'édifier
un monument à la mémoire du maréchal
omer on l'a prié de choisir le projet
qui lui agrée jamais madame rebelles n'a
répondu à cette lettre
[Musique]